Let's go next to our caller from the seven
zero eight area code.
Who's calling today from a seven zero eight
what does that mean?
Yes, it is.
Hi, this is max from Chicago.
Hey max, what's up?
Uh, not too much.
I actually wanted to get your thoughts on
something over Christmas.
Unfortunately, the topic of politics did come
up in my family and most of them are Democrat.
However, I noticed a lot of them repeating
these Centrus talking points.
You know, things like Bernie wants to go too
far or you know, Warren and Bernie's plans
would never work.
We need somebody more pragmatic.
I was just wondering what kind of arguments
do you formulate to counteract some of the
CNN and MSNBC talking points like that?
Well, it fits in a family situation.
I've said before, I would simply just try
to inquire as to how they came to those conclusions.
So when they say Bernie's gone too far left,
I would say, what's an example?
Policy?
And then either they won't have anything or
they'll say, well, his health care plan is
too far left.
And then you say, well why do you think that
so many countries have been able to do what
Bernie is proposing?
And it's working better than what we have
here.
Or, uh, if they say Elizabeth Warren's wealth
tax would, uh, would never work, or it would
never pass or whatever, then you say, Oh,
do you not think that inequality is a problem?
Oh, you do.
Well, how would you solve it?
I think that using the respectful, probing
questions, especially in family situations,
is the way to go.
You know, at rather than saying you've been
brainwashed by corporate media, that that's
less likely to get people to really examine
their beliefs.
Yeah.
That I knew not to take that approach.
I did.
I did try to make comparisons between Bernie
and Obama Oh eight, since all of them voted
for in level Obama and his, his original idea
at least.
So hope and change and things like that.
And they're really only, the only real response
they had was, well, Obama didn't go as far
as Bernie, so that's why it was okay.
Now I'm curious, are you folks are, it's not
a good excuse.
No.
But what I'm curious about is, because I get
a lot of emails from people who say, David,
when I see Joe Biden polling 30%, where are
these supporters of Joe Biden?
Because I'm on Reddit and everybody loves
Bernie, or Warren or yang or tool C or whatever.
I'm on Twitter and nobody's talking about
Joe Biden.
Where are these Biden supporters are the F
I've been making the case that the, the, the
sort of center left establishment democratic
voters, they're not participating nearly as
much in a lot of these online platforms.
And this skews people's approaches.
Are these folks you're talking about who voted
Obama and are more centrist, are they highly
engaged in like the internet political stuff
or are they mostly just watching corporate
media and living their lives?
Yeah,
I mean, I w I would assume yes,
probably more of the latter than the former.
I know that, you know, some of them are a
little bit more engaged online.
Um, mainly Facebook.
Uh, but I, I would imagine they get most of
their news from corporate media.
See, this is why a lot of people who are just
in the online space say, nobody's talking
about Biden.
There's no way he has 30% support.
There are huge swaths of the voting public
that just aren't participating on these forums.
And then you go to Christmas like you're talking
about and they're like, Oh yeah, we're all,
we're all, but you know, Bernie is going too
far.
Warren's going too far.
This is why I do believe the polls that Joe
Biden is in the lead.
I don't think it's an irreversible lead.
Bernie's been gaining on him over the last
couple of weeks.
But, uh, this is what I think it's important
for us to understand and not pretend like,
Oh, Biden's just going to get crushed.
He doesn't really have the support.
I think he does have it.
And it's from people like the ones you're
describing.
Yeah.
Well let's hope for the best.
Thanks for that, David.
I'm gonna try to give them some memberships
to your show.
Absolutely.
Max.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Take care.
Okay, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones right after
this